how excited are you about what the world
is about to see we're very excited
because
um you know I've always thought that you
get to rethink or redefine even what our
massive
current categories like search uh with
new technologies and so today is one of
those days where we get to reimagine
everything uh related to search with AI
there is talk about Google facing a
challenge in search really for the first
time in decades do you think that's
accurate well I mean I'd say I'm most
excited about starting a new race uh
when it comes to thinking about search
with Bing uh today and uh we
fundamentally believe that people should
go try out Bing as a way to think about
search differently right the fact that
we now have the core ranker right you
know it's only generationally that
search gets better and we have a
complete new algorithm for core ranking
we have Incorporated a new chat
functionality in the context of your
search result and then we've also made
the browser better by adding AI copilot
to it right so that all your web
activities enhanced so I feel like we've
now really taken a complete new approach
which I think is going to be very very
competitive when you ask the new Bing
something it responds in a natural
Almost Human way and then you can follow
up and it can really quite quickly feel
like a conversation with a human
presence do you feel that when you do
yeah I mean there are two things that I
feel like one is it's more of an answer
engine right off the gate when I ask it
even a complex query like if I say find
me the fair you know ferry schedule to
uh the San Juans and it'll come back
with an answer which has the results
with the winter schedule summarized with
even the wash DOT cameras and in
advising me to get reservations early
both ways and that answer is magical
right so it's more like less you know
it's from going from being a search
engine to even an answer engine then I
can ask it further questions to your
point right it could be like having a
real intelligent conversation but still
grounded yeah in the search results in
my query context uh and then I can even
take one of the documents that may come
back and I can use the co-pilot to
summarize it so it's sort of a very it's
bringing what I would have done maybe
three or four different places into one
flow so chat GPT if people are familiar
with any chat bot out there they're
familiar with that one created a
sensation when it it was released and my
understanding is this new chat function
in Bing is the foundation is more
powerful even than chat GPT is that
right that's right so we are basically
taking the next generation of the model
uh that today powerschat GPT and
building it in right into big is the
growth you know a step process or is it
more of a takeoff process all of these
are actually exponentials because each
time we have scaled these models we have
seen new emergent capabilities so we're
really excited about putting this next
Generation model and by the way the pace
here is going to be fast so we're
excited about this next phase so
emerging capabilities this is a phrase
that that I heard and then when I
understood what it meant my mind was was
blown so this is something correct me if
I'm wrong that you did not actively
teach the machine to do but that It
produced or came up with on its own do I
have that that's right so one of the
things that these large models have
exhibited right which is going from
let's say gpt25 to 3 three to three five
they've learned new capabilities like
coding for example software coding so
yes these large language models are
showing scaling effects where they show
emergent behavior and you don't teach it
to code it teaches itself to code that's
right because in some sense by training
on diverse set of data pre-training on
diverse set of data it builds up a
general circuit that is capable of
solving multiple tasks I mean the simple
intuition for me is let's say you have
one of these large models you train it
on let's say a lot of math formulas it
gets good at math but if you train it on
all the math formulas and you train it
on all of literature it gets better at
math why does it because fundamentally
like when you and I went to school we
learned math we learned language we
learned history and the general circuit
got better so a little bit of the same
intuition that if you train these models
on a lot of diverse data you then can
pick up new tasks so let's talk about
trust right people use the internet to
search for information they want to to
rely on it
can you trust what Bing now produces
using chat first of all a couple of
things one is we are grounding these
results in chat using the search results
so one of the differences between chat
GPT and this model Incorporated right
into being is the fact that it's in the
context of what you prompted it or the
search query itself right so that's one
the second thing is we are taking safety
as our first class consideration right
so we're building safety into the model
safety around the model how are you
defining safety so this is about just
making sure that say something like
harmful content right so you're making
sure that you are pre-trained in the
pre-training phase and then even at the
run time that harmful content is not
getting generated so if you ask it to
help you do something illegal what are
you saying it will not it will not and
and if it does we will immediately do
take down so in fact today in search
engines we have similar policies there
are always the web is full of the
internet is full of lots of different
content and then we do have robust
processes uh and Tech checks to ensure
that nothing harmful gets propagated so
the speed also will matter so with chat
GPT the other concern or any other
concern is is bias right it's trained on
billions of words produced by us which
means it contains the best of us but
also potentially the worst of us how can
you even begin to control or police that
in chat well I mean it's the same thing
again in today when you search on the
web you get what's available on the web
and so to some degree we are at the end
of the day going to take what is
available on the web and make sure that
any bias that is there that is in the
generative side of it is what we avoid
right so one of the things that we will
have is with if it is we in the
pre-training phase itself the diversity
of data helps but during the design side
of it right because that ultimately you
prompted it it didn't generate it so the
human is responsible ultimately for what
they prompt and what they see and
accepting what they see but so will
there be guidelines or limits though so
if somebody prompts it to write a joke
that might have been popular in 1975 but
would get you fired today for example
will it write the joke yeah and so that
well first of all I would even say the
you know this is where human agency is
at a premium uh you will always be able
to trip any new AI model uh because you
prompted it so I think we start with the
responsibility each of us as users have
to take and yes we will have many many
mechanisms to ensure that nothing biased
nothing harmful gets generated but it
there's potential in this new era that
we're in for the AI to produce things
that are inaccurate potential uh
potentially biased or hurtful and
potentially harmful
but it's on the user to know going in
that if you prompt it this may happen
that's correct and but in all of those
cases it's just not about the user
knowing but let's take the
inaccurate this is where grounding in
the search results matters so that means
it's not coming out of thin air but it's
coming from the search results
themselves second for bias you really
take steps during the training phase and
post training so that it's not biased or
same thing with harmful content or even
if you make a mistake and if somebody
notifies us what's the takedown policy
and how fast is it all of these things
are the things that are true today in
search engines and we'll apply the same
even going forward what's your biggest
worry now that this thing is going to be
Available To The World At Large I
wouldn't say it's
it's worry I would say the
the thing that I feel like here we are
in 2023 if you adjust for inflation
right
the world's GDP is negative so my
biggest worry is we need some new
technology that comes out of this very
celebrated Tech sector that starts
driving real productivity it's time for
some real Innovation so to me making a
category that all of us use every day
right which is search to be more
informed do research better that's a big
deal so therefore I am more worried of
us not innovating or more importantly
getting out there in the real world
making sure that we're producing
technologies that ultimately are driving
economic growth so economic you think on
the whole this is going to make
economies stronger larger grow faster
and therefore create more jobs than it
takes away in the long run I absolutely
think so which is that you know for
example I don't fall I don't buy this
lump of Labor fallacy right yeah there's
a fixed amount of jobs there's no I
think there will be more jobs in fact if
anything the more we democratize
knowledge work there will be more
knowledge work and if the more we can
take the drudgery out of knowledge work
the more productive we will be in the
work we do right whether it's sorting
through email and email responses or
writing code or searching all of these
categories I think can be redefined by
AI but have having seen what the AI can
do with composition with writing a
social media post with writing a cover
letter with writing a marketing plan uh
you know there are people making livings
right now doing jobs like that what do
you say to people watching who are
worried that what you're building might
make the economy grow but will disrupt
their job and their life in ways they
cannot predict first of all it's a great
point and I think even there I feel like
if you what this does really is create
the draft
but the draft has to be read by somebody
has to be edited by somebody approved by
somebody it's just that the throughput
maybe will improve right so it's the
same thing in software coding when we
introduce GitHub co-pilot what do you do
to software developers it removed the
drudgery of software development and
made it more enjoyable and of course it
will also bring more software developers
into the fold I think that will be the
case even in all these other fields
right so I think that some of the work
that we do today will be helped with
these draft Creations but at the end of
the day I think human judgment and
humans editing what these AIS produce
are going to be still at a premium do
you think it'll drive up wages
that's a great book I do believe it'll
drive up Pages because productivity and
wages are related so for example one of
the things that I love a lot about is
this one tool we introduced called Power
Platform this is where a domain expert
now can create an app or a workflow not
non-it people right so this is somebody
in the front lines maybe in healthcare
and Retail in manufacturing are able to
use think about it a natural language
prompt to create essentially an app what
does it do to them as soon as they go
from sort of you know being a Frontline
worker to having now created their some
digital artifact they become part of it
and that's wage support
I have to say uh I I was surprised first
by what the chat function could do how
natural it was there is a human presence
I know it's not a person but you feel it
I was also surprised though the
limitations there were times where I
couldn't answer there were times when I
answered wrong we corrected it it said
oops which is new
but it raises the question is this ready
are you confident for wide release
the only way for any new technology is
to be really perfected is to be in the
market with real human feedback if
anything is in particular with AI it has
to get aligned with human preferences
both personally and societally in terms
of the norms and that's why we want to
launch it we want to have all the safety
we want to have all of the things that
will make sure that no harms are created
but we need it out there in the real
world so yes we do feel the one other
thing I'd mention is the fact that it's
Incorporated inside a search that design
context matters uh it's not again an
open-ended tool it's in the context of
what you're searching for and as long as
it's useful in that context I think it's
going to be a great way for us to learn
and make these AI safer we have a major
election coming up in 2024 we've had
very contentious elections for two
cycles running and technology has been a
major disruptive Force
what's to say that this AI is not going
to be a kind of geyser of misinformation
disinformation since it can write posts
constantly well first of all what we're
lodging today is not about generating
posts it's about being able to search
the content and if anything quite
frankly to be able to sift through it
and get more of the authoritative
content to be summarized so that you're
not clicking on links that may not be as
authoritative so if anything this is a
tool to help with this information as
opposed to create more disinformation
fair point to where we are today however
one concedes the Nazis not too distant
future where
these Bots are capable of generating
essays papers whatever you the user want
to have generated
are you concerned about it being
hijacked in a way that produces lies
spam scams all sorts of trouble of that
magnitude and for sure we are and and
the way to and that happens today and so
these adversarial attacks and the
adversarial attackers can probably use
the same technologies that we are
talking about today to you know increase
the velocity of their attacks and we
have to stay ahead of it right so in
some sense we already have technologies
that are detect what was generated by a
bot was versus what was fact checked or
by a human being or what is an
authoritative Source who actually took
something that was generated but then
verified it so those are all things that
we already are going to be able to put
in place and so this at this point it's
out it's so it's going to happen the
question is can we as a society and we
as companies that are generating
products deal with these attacks and the
only way to do it is to be on the
Forefront of it so where is this all
going I know this is a major Milestone
today and I don't want to get away from
that fact however I do think it's also a
moment when you can see a little bit of
into the future you mentioned a co-pilot
is there a Moment In Time In Our
Lifetime where we are constantly moving
through our day with a kind of
artificial intelligence presence
alongside us helping us guiding us
answering our questions that to me is I
think what is going to happen right
which is I I think about this is not
about the human agency somehow going
away in fact if anything it'll put more
of a premium on how we spend our time
what we spend our time on and where our
attention goes and if anything these
co-pilots right whether it's when I'm
writing code when I'm searching or when
I'm doing a document I can stay more in
the flow because the co-pilot helps me
with some of the tasks and so that I
think is definitely the one pattern that
I see the other one is what you
described I think it's the age of
intelligent agents in fact what we are
just launching is a first version of it
where you have intelligence agents
intelligent agents agent it's something
that knows you helps you with your
everyday tasks uh that I think is
definitely something that we can look
forward to I'm closing out here but how
close are we to General artificial
intelligence a machine that can do all
the things a person can do I
I we're quite far from it this is very
early days okay these are powerful
models compared to sort of what was
there before but I don't think that
we're talking about this as AGI at all
if anything I think of this as
technology that truly helps us with
removing drudgery of everyday knowledge
work and net net you think it will
create more jobs than it will take I
believe it creates more I'll call it
both satisfaction in current jobs and
net new jobs
and then I have to ask and I sound a
little bit silly I feel a little bit
silly even contemplating it but some
very smart people ranging from Stephen
Hawkins to Elon Musk to Sam Altman who I
just saw in the hallway here your
partner at open AI have raised the
Specter of AI somehow going wrong in a
way that is lights out for Humanity
you're nodding her head you've heard
this too yeah is that a real concern and
if it is what are we doing look I mean
look runaway AI is if it happens it's a
real problem and so the way to sort of
deal with that is to make sure it never
runs away and so that's why I look at it
and say something let's start with
before we even talk about alignment and
safety and all of these things that one
should do with AI let's talk about the
context in which AI is used so and and
the design choices we make I think about
like the first set of categories in
which we should use these powerful
models or where humans unambiguously
unquestionably are in charge and so as
long as we sort of start there
characterize these models make these
models more safe and over time much more
explainable then we can think about
other forms of usage but let's not have
it run away it's very clear why people
would be excited right now but your
reputation as a leader is for having a
tremendous amount of empathy as well for
the people out there who are not excited
they're on the side of scared this feels
like a lot of change very quickly with
unknown consequences
what do you say to them
I would see
take some of what your real like in in
particular with something like being in
search
take your everyday usage what is it that
you expect from a search engine and see
if it's useful because here is the
interesting data point one third of the
time I go to a search engine today I get
results that are not satisfying so if we
can give you time back and you make it
much more useful to you then we'll
produce something of use we clearly are
in a kind of arms race when it comes to
AI it seems like everybody is coming out
with new products this year I think
you're the first with a major
announcement uh where is this going
well as you said it's a new race and
it's a new race and the most important
software category or the largest
software category in search uh let's
face it uh Google dominates it we are
thrilled to be here launching Bing to
compete and so we are really looking
forward to what the it's going to
rapidly evolve and so every day every
week every month it's going to get
better and so we're looking forward to
the the new search Wars would you rather
be you right now or the CEO of Google
well I'm thrilled to be CEO of Microsoft
all right the the car of humanity is at
a Crossroads to the left is dystopia to
the right is Utopia the blinker is on
which way is it pointing it's Utopia